hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo mi
nombre es juliette rian y lo saludo
desde casa
[Música]
la migración hacia eeuu desde
centroamérica es uno de los principales
retos del gobierno de joe biden y para
dar respuesta al presidente prometió
revertir las políticas migratorias de la
administración trump y atender las
causas del uso de esta última tarea le
fue encomendado a la vicepresidenta
kamala harris quien viajó a guatemala y
méxico con el objetivo de liderar los
esfuerzos diplomáticos para detener el
flujo migratorio desde los países del
conocido como triángulo norte guatemala
el salvador y honduras el mensaje es
claro
eeuu busca cooperación para abordar las
necesidades de los centroamericanos y
evitar el éxodo y reitera los que no
encuentran una opción que no migren
hacia la unión americana la pandemia la
inseguridad alimentaria el clima la
corrupción la violencia y la pobreza
están en la lista de la vicepresidenta
harris como los principales motivos de
la migración
al ir a jerónimo descuente mantener es
un testimonio revela la situación de los
centroamericanos que necesitan ayuda
mente
albina y su hija no pensaron regresar a
guatemala
pagaron a un traficante para que las
llevara eeuu y así poder pagar un
préstamo que usaron para construir una
habitación en su humilde vivienda
dejaron como garantía su casa y ahora
temen perder la hipoteca de mi casa y de
ahí por salvar esa eso este y ese otro
préstamos para irme para eeuu y dejarme
deportado y tengo dos deudas la
situación aquí es difícil la región
sufre sequía y la tierra no es apta para
la agricultura a duras penas logran
cosechar para su propio consumo tampoco
hay agua y la electricidad es escasa
como yo quisiera estudiar conmigo porque
tiene que quedarse
ciudades en el estudio
porque no hay
y aunque viajaron bajo las promesas
falsas de los coyotes se plantean volver
a intentarlo pese a que ya conocen los
peligros del viaje y las pocas
posibilidades que tienen de cruzar y
quedarse en eeuu
[Música]
más
nueva
o gloria es la enfermera en este pueblo
hogar de unas 700 personas y es de las
pocas que lleva mascarilla a pesar de la
pandemia ella ha sido testigo de los
engaños de los traficantes para llevar a
más personas de camino hacia el norte
han dicho que pueden pasar menores de 6
años con los padres pero al llegar a la
frontera los regresan
igual los que van con un niño de 16 15
16 años piensan que si van a pasar y no
hay al llegar a la frontera siempre a
veces los niños se quedan y los padres
regresan y no sé qué va a pasar con ella
albina jerónimo y su hija hacen parte de
los más de 228.000 guatemaltecos
deportados por estados unidos desde 2015
durante la administración del presidente
de nuestro méxico fue una guiador
momento de contener la migración con
agentes en las fronteras pero además se
convirtió en el destino de unas 68.000
personas que el gobierno republicano
devolvió agua el programa quédate en
mexico que obligaba a los solicitantes
de asilo a esperar una respuesta a sus
peticiones en un tercer país que no era
ni el suyo ni algo buscaban migrar hay
de prometió suspender la medida y ya la
olió definitivamente
son solicitantes de asilo con procesos
pendientes regresaron a méxico por orden
del gobierno trump con la promesa de que
esperarían allí una respuesta a sus
peticiones de refugio
yo en este proceso tres meses tres meses
o para cuatro meses
y ahora voy a esperar los 12 meses aquí
como el fueron devueltos a un país que
no conocían y que esperaban solo fuera
de tránsito soy sincera harley que están
poniéndome me siento mal porque yo no
puedo cómo voy a poder estar aquí cuando
ellos salen mi país huyendo por las
mismas ya que hay aquí hay bastantes
maleantes que se miran aquí es bien
peligroso y donde quede entre aquí solo
dos veces ha salido por cambios me da
miedo andar con mi niña a cuentagotas
sus solicitudes llegaban a las saturadas
cortes de inmigración por lo que la
espera se extendió de meses a años pero
la promesa del nuevo gobierno demócrata
de revertir las políticas de trump de
regreso la esperanza a miles de personas
hayden detuvo el programa que devolvía a
los solicitantes de refugio a méxico lo
que les permitió ingresar para esperar
sus trámites en eeuu
con la atención y muy agradecido por oír
nuestro llamado para decir para la
oportunidad de pasar la oportunidad de
poder hacer las cosas como son
las puertas se abrieron solo para los
que tenían procesos pendientes y aún
resta que se aclare su situación en la
unión americana
el gobierno de joe wagner 62.500 su
cuota anual de refugiados aunque
reconoció que sería un número difícil de
alcanzar en 2021 por las secuelas que
dejó el anterior gobierno por eso
continúan recordando a los que sueñan
con ir al país que no es el momento para
hacerlo hasta que inmigrantes de
france24 comenten en nuestras redes
sociales con el gran stan migrantes de
24 y siga con más información en france
24 y france 24
[Música]